[Music]
are you guys ever concerned with the
type of people your kids date or you
just trust their intuition oh man
shoot um I don't know about you for that
they've been a few they've cut me I've
been concerned Jada pinkett-smith
keeping it real when it comes to her
kids dating lives during a live read
Table Talk Q&A on Facebook Thursday
actually willow poor choices have been
spectacular
but it's my boys okay
Jada didn't spill names but she did
explain how the family handled it you
gotta go with the flow your kids aren't
always full of date people that you love
you know but I've learned that you
really have to just be there in support
because that can create a conflict that
really you can't get the actress's
series has been full of revelations in a
recent episode Jaden and Willow pulled
out their parents for starting them in
the industry too soon what is the part
that you think daddy and I have a
difficult time connecting to you with I
mean I only have one like really
terrible experience which is which is
whip my hair and there will be more
where that came from
Jada T's distilled to come appearance by
her hubby Will Smith when he visited the
read table back in April I said I yeah I
promise I'll stop will and I actually
gonna have a very interesting
conversation about how our journey in
regards to transforming a marriage into
a life partnership
and and to even get an understanding of
that and understanding more of that you
know you've come to the episode but it's
gonna be a really powerful discussion
and how my mother and how willow and
Jaden the whole family has been involved
in this transformation so
[Music]